this is a production of Cornell
University
okay thanks everybody for coming and uh
and yeah gosh I'm excited I have some
some fun slides to present today
um and yeah I'll just hop right in so uh
Different Strokes for different folks
this is a phrase coined by Muhammad Ali
talking about how he has different
boxing strategies for different
opponents based on their strengths and
weaknesses
um and this is a really nice parallel
for what I'm going to be talking about
today which is that weed species are
very different based on their biology
and the traits that they have and so we
we should really be tailoring our
management based on that
so uh first off I want to tell you a
little bit about my position I'm mostly
extension and I do try to hit every
corner of the State uh and I cover all
crops as well as recently added a
community IPM uh component so I cover
backyard gardens and weeds and natural
landscapes
and I just want to start by giving some
examples of weeds in different systems
that that I've viewed from my travels
across the state and um this is this is
one that kind of stands out is
glyphosate tolerance soybeans where the
farmers are really relying on on
glyphosate to achieve their their weed
control and um
typically the most problematic weeds in
these systems are also tolerant of
glyphosate or have developed resistance
to glyphosate as is the case to a tall
water hemp and horse wheat
in great Vineyards we've we've
established this great
um trellis system to to help our our
perennial uh grapevines Thrive and it
turns out that there are several
perennial Vining weeds that also tend to
thrive in this environment hedge
vineweed Virginia creeper also Poison
Ivy and others
um
and so it kind of It kind of fits there
and then in greenhouses on benches I I
was happy that I worked at Betsy of last
month to attend and presented the
greenhouse IPM in depth which is
fantastic and um
there's a very specific set of weeds in
in greenhouses on benches and the one
thing that they have in common is that
they all can't have the ability to
forcefully eject their seed and shoot
those seeds five or six feet away which
is enough to hop up onto the benches or
into hanging baskets or from pot to pot
um and so each of these three examples
here I've actually LED or co-led uh
trials and have have that that data up
online it's also I also went into detail
in my last uh Horticulture seminar a few
years ago and that's up on the web if
you're interested more
um and a few other examples of of weeds
that have come to thrive in different
systems
um this is a a good example here from
our afri project looking to try to
improve establishment of of conifers in
the first few years it's it can be very
difficult uh there's typically High
mortality so one of the sets of
treatments that we're looking at is uh
is with weed management so we're
comparing cultivation which is kind of
shallowly disturbing the soil and we're
doing this about three times over the
course of the summer
uh mowing about once a month wood chips
which were applied at about a four inch
depth
and herbicides which were sprayed in the
spring and then in the fall typically
while the trees were were still a little
bit dormant
um and it's interesting because because
this is side by side this is all in the
same field and you know a very similar
starting point in terms of which weeds
were present
and we're coming into the third year
here and and we're still taking data and
analyzing the data but just to
anecdotally show you some pictures
uh and and tell the story uh each of
these these treatments looks very
different nowadays in the third year so
for example with cultivation
uh it's it there is a lot of hairy
gallon soga and this is one of our
fastest weeds to emerge and and uh
flower and set seed it's about three
weeks from emergence to flowering so if
we're cultivating every five or six
weeks that's plenty of time for this
week to complete its life cycle
in the mowing system we don't actually
have many weeds per se in this system
but
um instead we have a lot of our seated
cover crop which is a mixture of grasses
uh and clovers it's our are low growing
and require minimal Mowing and are
actually kind of smothering out uh the
other weed species it seems in the wood
chip system this is really dominated by
Canada thistle and Quack grass pictured
here and both of these weeds are
perennial with very aggressive root
systems and they spread and have a lot
of energy embodied in those root systems
so they uh can can seemingly easily push
through four inches of wood chip mulch
and then in the herbicide system that
this will look very clean very weed free
for the first month or two after the
herbicide applications
um but those soil applied herbicides do
break down over time and so you get some
late season weeds that are able to
germinate and come through uh like
barnyard grass here
okay one final systems comparison that
shows more this type of uh you know
different weed species coming to thrive
in different situations again we have
and I should mention this is an organic
uh winter squash this is a delicata uh
we have cultivation again compared to a
black plastic mulch and a straw
multiplied by hand at at a very high but
a kind of a standard rate of nine tons
per acre as well as a rolled Rye system
and so this is a cover crop a rye cover
crop that is grown over the winter and
through the spring and then is Roller
crimp to terminate it into a mulch
and Midway through the season
um most of these are are looking pretty
good in terms of weed control and and
crop health I think the one outlier was
was the rolled Rye system which which uh
we struggled with for a few different
reasons I think there may have been some
allelopathy uh potentially this colder
more compacted soils maybe some nitrogen
immobilization uh but yeah so we
struggled it with with the Rye system a
little bit even though we uh enacted it
in two a little bit different ways each
year over the two-year study
um but what I really wanted to point out
here is is the differences in the weed
species and I've used principal
components analysis to help tell the
story here I'm just going to kind of
highlight a few of the examples
so Colin personally was strongly
associated with the cultivation
treatment and a common person this kind
of makes sense is it has these very
thick waxy leaves and it's often able to
survive cultivation by re-rooting and
taking some of that energy stored in the
leaves and making new roots
and common Ragweed was strongly
associated with the rolled Rye treatment
uh Matt Ryan and others have shown this
before in that the the Ragweed is one of
our earliest emerging species so it's
able to emerge before we roll down the
Rye into a suppressive mulch
winter we we don't think of typically as
a weed but it's a plant out of place in
this context and um
interestingly this was a winter wheat
straw so I'm wondering where this winter
we came from
um and and actually most of the time
when I see straw in use it does bring in
a signature amount of grain we were
lucky that this was winter wheat straw
rather than oats or spring wheat because
those would have grown very tall and
headed out whereas winter wheat requires
a vernalization or overwintering period
and stayed low growing for us
uh the there was a lot of smartly there
are a few different species of smart
weeds and they were mixed uh throughout
the trial I think that there was just
generally a high level of of smartweed
seeds in the in the soil and seed bank
um that so just by sheer numbers they
were able to to uh to make their way
through our treatments
so what I'm really showing and trying to
show in all of these examples is
something called Community assembly
Theory which is more of an ecological
principle that can be applied to weeds
in that the the species that come to
dominate or thrive in a particular field
are really a function of what's there to
begin with and which of those species
can make their way through various
filters
uh the filters can be abiotic like
temperature and climate filters
um they can be biotic like weed to weed
or plant plant interactions herbivory
but a lot of times the strongest filters
determining the presence of weeds for
which ones survive or not is human
management to tillage is the herbicides
that are used is really impact the the
success of weeds
um and a nice way to visualize this is
through a Swiss Cheese model and you may
have seen this in a different context at
the height of covid and that you know
you you you you want to uh wear a mask
you want a social distance get
vaccinated each of these things stacking
them together reduces the the likelihood
that a viral particle will will slip
through and and uh possibly gets sick
and it's the same type of principle with
with weeds
foreign
so some of the differences between Weed
species that can impact their success
include their life cycle are they an
annual that produces thousands of seeds
are they a perennial that is perhaps
more reliant on spreading via the roots
uh monocots tend to have a a growing
point
a meristem that is protected at the soil
line whereas dicots the meristem is up
on the on the the ends of the shoots and
exposed to things like mowing or flame
weeding or contact herbicides the
morphology the the height and you know
spreading nature of weeds is another
important factor as is the
photosynthesis type which can can impact
the success of a plant in drought years
or wet years and there's many other
traits
um some of these are down to the
molecular level like like how the
species respond to herbicides do do they
have the molecular
um you know shapes of some of their
mechanisms in at the cellular level that
allows herbicides to bind and block
particular mechanisms that are important
to the plant uh can can the plant
metabolize certain herbicides to to
Simply make them ineffective
and
one of the the important factors that
determine the success of different weed
species that you may not think about or
at least I didn't for a while was when
do weeds tend to emerge and different
species tend to emerge at different
times of the year typically based on the
accumulation of Growing Degree Days
and this is some work led by Matt Ryan
that that I um took a piece of and added
some review to and and showed that
um yeah species have some species
anyways like say barnyard grass here
have an emergence Peak that can be
targeted uh by management
so for example
um this
um
shaded uh band here is is a hypothetical
emergence Peak and
um here I have a few different examples
or scenarios of ways Farmers might
Target that Peak so the crop here is
represented by these vertical lines
increasing in height and then the X's
represent various direct controls like
herbicides or tillage or cultivation
um so one simple way is to Simply
consolidate you know some of your direct
controls during that period when weeds
are just emerging they're very small and
when weeds are small they're most
susceptible to to Direct Control it's
when they're they're kind of the weakest
um another way is to to uh ensure that
you have residual herbicides overlapping
during this important period of
emergence and similarly with residue
mulches those mulches break down over
time so ensuring that that's applied
before the emergence Peak is important
planting later can help farmers just
simply avoid an emerge an emergence Peak
if they have that flexibility and
planting earlier can get the crop
established and give it a height
advantage over the the emerging weeds uh
a fallow period is is excellent and I
think kind of the gold standard if if
the farmer has that flexibility to
Simply you know repeatedly till or spray
during that period to control those
emerging weeds without having to worry
about damaging their crop potentially
and a cover crop can achieve a similar
effect
foreign
which crops might be used or be adjusted
to to
fit the the timing of when weeds emerge
in a particular field if the weeds are
emerging in the early part of the season
if if the problematic species like a lot
of our summer annuals emerge around this
time uh Farmers may consider shifting to
later planting periods to avoid that
period uh or use crops like Alfalfa or
winter cereals that are established
ahead of time and have a competitive
advantage through that
for mid-season weeds it's a little
tricky a farmer may try to use short
season crops to avoid this peaky
emergence period
and then for late season weeds which are
typically winter annuals uh earlier
crops will allow the Harvest and you
know get the crop out of the field so
that you can then take care of the weeds
again without having to worry about
putting the crop in the way
and the other thing we did with this
work was look at the previous literature
and uh for for each of the species that
we are interested in and and
um kind of initiate a bit of a virtual
common Garden experiment in that uh
we're using them these models that were
created which are primarily based on
Growing Degree Days and then plugging in
the same data for each of these models
based on hardiness zones
um that are found in New York so 4A
would be like up in the Adirondacks 7A
would be down on Long Island
and yeah for for uh most of these the
data corresponded to what we had found
experimentally
um
but yeah it was interesting and I guess
it makes sense that that there was about
a month a month and a half difference
between when a given species would be
predicted to emerge in a warmer climate
versus a cooler plant
and one of the kind of initially
perplexing things is that you know some
of these models were very different and
um for two of these that can be
explained in that their winner annuals
that can also be summer annual so I
think that they're modeling two
different populations
um but some of these like Redwood these
are summer annuals and there's quite a
variation with
um when the models predicted emergence
and
um I think this shows that that there
are different their population level
differences in that
uh pigweed in one part of say the us or
Europe or wherever
um May emerge or can be predicted to
emerge at one time you know maybe
earlier or later than another population
so I think that has to do with the
history of the field and and how the
selection pressure has played out in the
past for each population
um so that's just something that going
forward we'll have to to account for if
we're going to be using these models to
make recommendations for farmers
but yeah there's there's a lot of
biology traits that that of impact which
weeds are successful and which aren't
um and a lot of that information is
available in these two fantastic uh
recent books that were published in the
past couple years uh our own uh Antonio
Di Tomaso is a co-author on both of
these uh this uh managed Weeds on your
farm was lead authored by Charles Muller
the late great Charles Muller who is at
uh at Cornell
um and these are these have been just
fantastic resources for educators like
me it includes these tables so you have
all of the the common weed species and
most of the key biological traits that
are going to impact their management
that now if I get a call from a farmer
about
how do I what should I be doing about
this weed say shatter cane I can quickly
remind myself
um you know what are the the pertinent
um traits there and yeah sorry is the
amount of Weeds on your farm is that is
that online that's online yes that's
that's available for free online and
yeah I encourage you to check it out
um
sorry yeah no problem and uh yeah and
it's been these books have been a huge
help
um and for example in this weed
identification and management webinar
series uh that several of us put
together with uh with webinars on weed
management for grasses for broadleafs
for lead management soybeans
um I I in particular really lean heavily
on those two books and um and actually
some of the slides that I use were even
um pre-made by the Dita maso group and
Terry marshner in particular about how
to identify various species and I'll
just quickly go through a few of these
um but something that I did was really
try to boil down the management
information even further I just said you
know maybe two bullet points uh for
example Velvet Leaf has these these
densely hairy you know velvety drooping
leaves that herbicides a lot of times
can just run right off of and and so
there's issues with uptake
um but it can be controlled uh
effectively when the leaves when there's
four leaves or less
and Velvet Leaf doesn't typically
produce seeds until the end of August so
for shorter season or earlier season
crops again we could we could try to
harvest those early and then come
through and effectively
um till or burn down the remaining
velvet leaves to prevent weed seed
production
bird cucumber is uh it can be
problematic in field crops it looks
somewhat similar to our cultivating
cucumber it has these large seeds that
enable it to emerge from rather deep in
the plow layer most of our seeds just
emerge in the top inch or two
um and yeah what I'm calling an Achilles
heel or something that kind of sticks
out about each species is that for a
bird cucumber it doesn't produce very
much seed and those seeds last a long
time so there's relatively little or few
numbers of Brewer cucumber emerging in a
particular field I think it's a good
candidate for spot treatments
pigweeds we have several pigweed species
in New York
um and two of them are resistant to
different herbicide classes
with the pigment species I think one of
the important Achilles heels is that the
seeds don't live very long in the soil
they have a half-life of about a year so
if a farmer is really able to step up
their control uh for about four years
they should be able to almost completely
eliminate the pygmy from the seed bank
first Lane I mentioned earlier has very
thick backseat leaves
um but it is very low growing and it's
relatively shade intolerance so it's
it's uh susceptible to to crop
competition uh from crops like corn
and smothering the other means
uh crabgrass also is fairly low growing
and spreading um so if it's in a long
um competing with with more erect
grasses if you're able to keep your
mowing height higher uh can kind of
shift the competitive the competitive
Advantage uh to those other species
barnyard grass
has seed that unlike some of our grasses
or other sweet species where the seed
almost immediately drops to the soil and
is incorporated into the soil seed bank
Fargo Grass kind of retains its seed a
little bit longer and through the fall
so it could potentially be be removed
through several different
mechanisms either hand removal or or
mechanized Harvest Time weed seed
destruction
horse weed it can be a winter or summer
annual I mentioned earlier it it is
um likely resistant to glyphosate around
the state expose some other herbicide
classes
um but it has these very very small
seeds it's the seeds are wind blown
unlike a lot of our agricultural weeds
that have seed that just drop straight
to the ground or sweet seeds are tiny
and and they're so in order to be wind
blown to be taken by the wing
um and so they're so small they don't
have enough energy to push through very
much soil they typically only germinate
and emerge from basically the soil
surface
so they're very susceptible to tillage
or soil disturbance to put them deeper
or crop residue or mulches to prevent
their their successful emergence
common Burdock and spotted Napoli are
both biennials and typically only see
them
um in very minimally managed hay fields
some perennials uh Canada thistle
field bind weed
delay crack grass and yellow nutsedge
um are are all perennials with very
aggressively spreading root systems and
uh these these species they store a lot
of energy and carbohydrates in those
roots so it can take many years of
repeated management to effectively
control these perennial species and one
tip that's typically suggested is that
farmers use systemic herbicides that
particularly applied in the fall when
these weeds are preparing for winter
they're bringing carbohydrates and
resources down into their root system to
store that over the winter help them get
through the winter and so if you apply a
herbicide at that time it takes the
herbicide with it down to the root
system and helps us destroy the roots
so those are just some some quick
examples
um and and this this type of of
extension I I found a lot of uh support
for it there seems to be a lot of
interest and demand from Farmers uh I I
get a lot of calls and questions after
presentations you know hey what you know
what is this weed that I have I'll get
i'll get photos from a phone and then
very quickly follow how do I kill it
um so this this type of management uh or
uh extension I found to be um very
effective and I'd like to try to
continue to build on this momentum
because this this webinar series these
two great books that just came out uh we
have some momentum going in this line
um and so in
looking to establish uh upcoming you
know new projects new Grant proposals I
I wanted to build on this but at the
same time I didn't want to bore Farmers
by going over all the species that they
don't have they they want to know about
the you know the handful of species that
that they're really having a problem
with not necessarily all these others so
to make this more specific
um I I was thinking back to some work
that I had done in grad school
uh doing germinable weed seed bank assay
so this is this is where we would take
soil samples
um typically 10 samples from across the
field mix those up bring them back to a
greenhouse uh let the weeds emerge
continue to water and encourage weeds to
emerge over the course of a summer
record all those species
um I'm thinking okay this might be a
good way to bring this this uh
biological based
um you know management information to to
a farm and really look at and tailor it
to the species that they have
um and in this particular trial
um or project
we we found some interesting things you
know we saw okay that we
EDS um
Community composition with these seed
bank analyzes was excuse me was
um
somewhat somewhat um explained by
geo-chromatic factors like latitude
longitude Growing Degree Days and then
to a lesser extent by soil factors
academic factors like pH uh soil organic
matter
um but what one of my regrets is that we
didn't include any management
information about the farm like are they
using tillage what type of herbicides
what type of crops are they planting
um and I so I think that adding that
kind of information would be would be
really interested and um so a group of
us got together and we were successful
in in doing just that and applying for a
new project that that uses these beads
seed bank analyzes to to do this type of
trait based uh extension
um and we'll we'll be visiting 50 Farms
this fall we're Midway through that
already
um and these Farms are fruit vegetables
uh you know organic conventional field
crops there's a lot of urban Farms
they're participating
um and it's it's primarily an extension
project so for each Farm we'll provide
photos of of their problem species and
how to identify them with key features
um show how their weed seed bank
compares to others do you have a small
weed seed bank or is it is it rather
large a lot Farmers like seeing how they
compare to other farmers
uh but I think most importantly is we're
going to really look hard at the species
that they have and work to come up with
tailored management recommendations uh
and and base that on the tools that are
available to each Farm you know I I'm
not going to come in and say
you just need to add on uh one more
piece of Swiss cheese and by the way it
costs fifty thousand dollars
um
I'd rather come in and say okay if you
move this piece of Swiss cheese and inch
to the left you're going to dramatically
improve your weed management
um really at no additional cost
um so looking for those types of of kind
of win-win situations
um based on adjusting Farmers timing of
planting maybe crop selection
um and and herbicides other factors
so there'll be 50 farms and so it's
likely that if you're a farmer in New
York state there's going to be one of
those 50 is going to be very similar to
your own situation with the weeds and
what tools you have available so we'll
be translating these recommendations
into several languages having them
available in print and online
um and so far yeah we have booked the
the 50 Farms that I I would like to uh
give a big thank you to uh county-based
uh extension Educators as well as
um
researchers that have um you know strong
um you know connections with Growers
like like Greg Peck who helped get the
word out
um and and the other thing that helped
us is that we had a 500 stipend for
Farmers to participate uh although I do
have some qualms with uh how Cornell
handles the stipends
um but yeah there this was
um this was this is primarily extension
but we do have some research questions
that we'll be investigating how do
particular species correlate with with
crops you know what determines where
species are you know where they are
um and in which situations uh we'll also
be looking and screening for some
herbicide resistance for suspected
species
you're doing some novel things related
to heat and enzymes to attempt to
deplete weed seed banks
um and I'm we're also open to other
questions this will be kind of an
interesting data set with 50 farms and
and all of the weed species encompassed
or these are the Farms so we're open to
to collaboration if anyone has any uh
additional questions
so a little bit more on the Heat and the
enzymes
um so
heat particularly above 150 degrees
Fahrenheit really just starts to cook
weed seeds and
um there are a few ways that that this
can be established uh on farms one of
them is so using clear plastic uh
solarizing and this is kind of a fun
story there was a
high school student in the Hudson Valley
who was interested in solarization and
went to his local uh County extension
service who put him in touch with Steve
reiners who put him in touch with me
because I had done some solarization
before and uh and we we chatted a few
times over zoom and
um I just gave him one or two
suggestions about replication and some
details but this is really his
independent project and he really he got
his own funding and just uh you know did
this amazing work over the summer
and found treatment differences it he
was looking at comparing plastic versus
biodegradable film for solarization he
found uh hotter temperatures achieved in
the plastic than the biodegradable mulch
or film and um likewise more uh
mineralization of MP and K in the higher
temperatures
um and he actually took this work and uh
was successfully he got first place at a
local science fair uh and is now in his
first year at Cornell I was hoping he
was going to be on hand to sign
autographs today
um but uh yeah very very fun uh project
to to collaborate on with him
um other ways that that he can be used
to to Target weed seeds um that I was
actually getting questions about from
interested Farmers
um you know steam is used to some extent
but it takes a long time
um and it's not feasible on a large
scale probably
um they're curious about boiling water
and uh they were thinking this could be
applied quicker to larger areas
um so I I borrowed a camping stove and
had these very small plots set out
um uh rep or a representative of
actually fairly large volumes of boiling
water applied to the soil and
unfortunately there wasn't a significant
effect
um I think that the boiling water didn't
penetrate deep enough and I think that
it cooled off fairly rapidly to not not
actually kill the weed seeds that we're
hoping for and of course with perennial
weeds it's going to be less effective
anyways as they're likely emerging from
from root stuff
um but I was still very excited about
this other new idea to to potentially
degrade weed seeds and that weed seeds
are typically covered in a waxy coating
that includes cuten and xylin and these
materials help protect the seed there
are certain fungi and bacteria that can
break down that seed coat using enzymes
they can exude cutenase or xylinase to
help them break through and uh and then
break down the interior of the seed
after that
um and these these uh these enzymes
actually you can purchase online through
the magic of recombinant DNA technology
um and so I actually did that and uh
incubated uh known quantities of Lamb's
quarters seed for about eight hours to
each of these treatments and then bury
the seed for six months and in the
living soil that was kept moist
um and thinking that okay if the uh the
enzyme and it gets the job started and
breaking down the seed coat perhaps
um the ambient fungi and other microbes
in the soil could take advantage of
those wounds and and kind of finish the
job so to speak
uh unfortunately there was no no
significant difference between uh any of
the treatments and uh and that was
unfortunate but I thought well maybe let
me uh make sure I'm covering all my
bases here and test the German ability
The Germ rate of the seed because if
there was any type of damage
um you know perhaps it's um it would
allow the sea to imbibe water more
quickly and impact the germination and
it actually did so there was a
significant difference for the
treatments
um based on whether they're exposed to
the enzymes or not and this is a modest
difference I'll admit but I think it's
it's still an encouraging result and
that you know maybe with improved
methods
um if we do this again in the next few
years we can increase that result if we
can get close to a hundred percent of
the seeds to emerge then a farmer could
just come through and control all those
all the wheat the weeds their soil and
basically have weed-free conditions
I also want to mention that um we've
done uh some work in uh investigating
this can new breed of mechanical weeding
tools that is coming online to kind of
reduce the burden on herbicides and and
hand labor Lynn suznowski and I both
presented at the Northeast mechanical
weed uh control field day this past
summer and Lynn actually recently
purchased a Nile Oz weeding robot from
France
um and gave us a great opportunity to
help set up these or help adjust these
cultivation implements on it and uh our
uh two undergraduate summer research
assistants Eric burdham and Juliana Lee
got to help with that I think it was one
of the highlights of their summer and
they're now in their Junior and senior
years at Cornell and I think have very
Bright Futures ahead of them
so just to wrap everything up with a
nice little bow
um I mentioned there's another sense of
Different Strokes for different folks
that you might be more aware of than the
boxing scent and that and this is the
the way that Sly and the family's Stone
used in their song everyday people is
that people are different and you know
people do things in different ways
um and you know we should celebrate that
diversity
um and really that applies to weed
management and that there's you know
there's no single right way to manage
weeds
um you know you can do it a million
different ways and and I'm
improving and um you know not not
letting my own biases affect uh my
extension but you know meeting Farmers
where they are and I one minute I may
meet with a large scale
um you know conventional grower just
talking about different herbicides and
the next minute I may be talking with a
small scale male organic farmer about
hand tools um so you know it's there is
there's there's so many ways to do it um
successfully and as long as
um you know I'm always trying to to
reduce risks and improve the weed
control yes but also reduce risks
related to the environment human health
and the economic bottom line or the farm
um
and actually this is a great example uh
in itself of Different Strokes for
different folks and that some research
from Maine showed that there's no single
best hand tool uh you know they're all
good at different things and
um you know the ergonomics of each of
them fits with different people in
different ways based on how tall they
are or other factors
um and so we actually applied for some
funding through the vegetable program
work team and we have about 20 different
hosts that travel around the state but
kind of a whole library to different
field events so farmers can test them
out and see which one works for them
um
whoops and in another sense of Different
Strokes for different folks is that
people have different learning styles so
a lot of us in extension are really
branching out from just presentations
and and one-on-one
um using things like Active Learning and
video podcasts
um and something that I'm excited about
hopefully unveiling in the next year or
two is something called a garden
notebook a a campaign I hope to uh
establish on social media
um that utilizes some of the drawing and
painting skills of a few of us in the
IPM program to reach out to a new
audience probably backyard gardeners who
might keep this type of notebook with
Pest management information what are the
key identifying characteristics of
different weeds for example uh and maybe
we can work in some research-based uh uh
management tips in there as well
so I've tried to include some
acknowledgments as as I've went I I've
been really lucky to work with a wide
variety of people in different
disciplines as a lot of us are
struggling with weeds
um and I just want to thank the New York
State Department of Ag and markets as
well as DEC
Northeast air and USDA for funding
related to some of the work I presented
so thank you
any questions
yeah so you know we've been reading
about electric computers and lots of
sports
there's other newer kind of ways
is that technology good yeah
right yeah I'm guessing I should repeat
that for example
um yeah so the question is uh for Marvin
about uh you know what is the status of
uh robotic and advanced uh weeding
equipment
um yeah so
um a lot of it is still in the
development stage but yeah there are our
yeah I used to say 10 I used to say 20.
I don't know there's there's maybe 30
plus startups now
um that are trying to tackle this
they're seeing this opportunity of okay
we're struggling with some herbicide
resistance we're struggling with labor
shortages can advanced technology kind
of take the place here
um and a lot of it is uh you know being
at the early stages and with economies
of scale it's at the very nascent stages
so it's it's it's very expensive and um
typically it's it's mostly applied and
very high value props particularly in
California where there's a high density
of high value crops so they can station
a company there and maybe have a handful
of these tools share them between uh all
the large farms in the area but um yeah
we're they're starting to expand out
from from uh California
um
it's it's going to be a while yet I
think before the average farmer in New
York has one of these fancy robots but
it does seem like prices are coming down
and you know they're they're becoming
bit by bit more viable
so
yeah
um there's some other different answer
technique it sounds like there's like
weakness anticipate from
um
if they're like the copper Advance
predict but yet you're against the right
locations or
um
yeah
that's a great question uh and what was
your name player Claire so Claire was
asking uh about you know how far in
advance can we predict certain weed
problems and which species are going to
be maybe problematic or challenging in
certain situations
um and
yeah that's that's a great question
um I think that to some extent you know
some of these things are a little bit of
a no-brainer like the okay life is safe
tolerant needs and glyphosate if you're
only spraying glyphosate
um
and there are certain
um Suites of weeds that are typically
problematic in like organic vegetables
or you know depending on what type of
crop it is that you're growing or grapes
like I mentioned
um so to some extent we can get you in
the right ballpark just based on like
okay this is the crop and this is the
frequency and timing of tillage as in
the herbicides use perhaps
um but there's this other factor of what
was the starting point of of the seed
bank what's the history of the field
before it was grapes was it in you know
was it pasture or what you know what
what seed bank had built up there and
that would maybe still have a legacy of
that in that given site
um and and if you're and I mentioned
most of our weed seeds do you know just
fall straight to the ground but some
like dandelions and like horse weed do
blow in so what is the Farm's proximity
to new sources of those weeds are you
near a big field of dandelions that's
going to constantly be coming in on
um so yeah I think that there's there's
a certain Baseline level we can predict
but there's an overall level of
we have
um kind of random effects that it's
going to be unique to each situation
Brian are are there any examples of uh
mobile
um steam based
reading machines not weeding machines
but a field treatment sheets yeah they
do that in in Harlem you know with with
Sandy soils and around here with much
more Rocky and variable soils I could
imagine that might be a problem but
that's quite successfully oh really okay
yeah so uh Bill asked about uh you know
what are there examples of of you know
tractor drawn steam uh readers and I'm
Vaguely Familiar with some that um that
can steam and and have the soil covered
as they go there's there's like a
covering that keeps the heat in it
follows the seam
um and I know there was some research a
while ago uh that looked at
um
steam in combination with tillage
because it can be difficult to get the
steam throughout that soil column so if
you're if you're rototilling and also
applying the steam
um it seems to it seems to do a better
job it was the the take-home message
that I remember so I just I'm assuming
that there are examples of that as they
you know I don't know if this was like a
research based a one-off that the
researcher made but um yeah and and I'd
be curious to hear more about in Holland
are they I will try to dig up some
photographs like certainly took pictures
of it so I have to go and try to find it
yeah just for for comparison sake for
greenhouses is is the most common area
where I see Steam being used and
um they'll they'll get the temperature
up they'll do it by bed and so there's a
hose that has holes in it that allows
the steam to come out and that's
um covered each bed so I think they do
it four times to cover its ethical
Greenhouse another 30 minutes each
application yeah
15 years ago never really took off I
think there's a lot of complexity with
um trying to drive around an orchard
with the machine that'd be steam
that
um
a lot of energy
they do have it for Landscapes and then
they've actually adapted it also to the
phone
so that the heat stays in place longer
foreign
schools yeah yeah and that I think
controlling the existing weeds with heat
it requires less energy than going into
the soil and actually killing the weed
seeds but yeah that's interesting yeah
well let's set a question about
um since you get around quite a bit in
the state and see a lot of farmers see a
lot of fields there's props I'm
wondering you know one of the things
about climate change that we've always
talked about is the weeds are really
gonna have a competitive even more of a
competitive advantage over a lot of our
our crop plants and I'm wondering if
you're starting to see some of that
um come to you know come to be that you
know start to see the species changing
or difficulty controlling weeds may be
related to climate change what are the
Growers saying because yeah what do you
what are you hearing what are you seeing
yeah that's a great comment uh so yeah
Greg asks uh and comments about uh
climate change yeah bringing in
potentially new species to this area or
making our existing species maybe more
competitive with crops
um yeah I think it's it's just very hard
to to generalize because uh and Kerry
marshner and Tony and tommaso have a
uh Smith lever project
um looking into this and and providing
some extension results right now and and
they've reviewed the literature and it's
it it's very hit or miss and species
dependent you know based on you know C3
C4 uh grasses uh dicots and
um yeah
how certain species are gonna how will
fare in higher CO2 versus higher
temperature or more drought there's just
so much to it that it's just it's it's
it we can't make a generalization so for
these educational materials we're kind
of providing key examples here and there
of what you know what might happen
um but um as far as you know what we're
actually seeing on the ground
um yeah uh Tony is is actively
um looking for
um uh Johnson grass is one that he is is
concerned about as it's a very
problematic weed south of us and so you
know if that comes into New York it
could be in trouble
um we we've already had uh introductions
of of others that are herbicide
resistant like Palmer amaranth which is
I believe native to the desert Southwest
U.S and perhaps due to climate change it
is now able to to complete its life
cycle in Northern climates like New York
um and that is I think typically
regarded as one of the world's most
competitive and problematic species so
and that's unfortunately now in New York
in a few different counts
um
so yeah but
natural ecosystems you talk about
agriculture but when I drive around I
see you know Japanese spots
okay that's nice
yeah yeah and I I I have um yeah like I
added this small component so maybe five
percent of my position it includes
backyards and natural areas and so I'm
paying a little bit of attention but um
I think it's mostly um you know New York
State DEC and and others um USDA
um
um there's there's someone at the USDA
facility here who's looking at bio
controls I think that if you remember
purple loose strife several years ago
that just covered places like Montezuma
and now you can go and and you don't
really see it as much as they they found
a successful bio control it's one of the
most successful examples of Bio control
um and I think that that's where it
really has to come from that there's
been you know there's been efforts of
eradication based on spraying and people
going out with cruise but it's just so
widespread at this point especially like
Japanese knotweed and the garlic mustard
that
um you know I don't think we have the
human power to to go out and make a
significant Dent unless there was a
massive funding um but so I think that
the way forward is really through bio
control and with these landscape level
issues like that and and that's an
active area of research
um elsewhere that I just haven't taken
part in as of yet
see
all right Brian thank you that was all
right
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu